hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the obscenely requested
whack your boss now this game is a
little gory from what I've seen I
haven't played it myself but I've seen
pictures they involve a lot of blood
spraying on a lot of walls so if you're
not into that stuff don't watch this
video or if you're morbidly curious go
right ahead but Marvel arts not condone
the wack inch of any bosses or anyone
for that matter
markiplier does not also does not
condone the usage of the word wack in
common vernacular hello oh no no no no
wrong wrong wrong it's come to my
attention that you're not measuring up
though you'll need to stay late again
with no overtime yeah your project has
to be completely redone you can't seem
to do anything right I can do one thing
right I'll write you up again - oh
you're just not measuring up that's
three more demerits this week wait a
minute see this looping through
different insults for me how dare you
wait what
thanks for the assist buddy
oh god already okay I asked for too much
why would I play this game last time I
played a whack your game was whack your
ex when I did the wasabi challenge which
you can find in the description below if
you really want to see that whoa wait
it's the cleaner from John wick I paid
him a gold doubloon and it was gone well
I was over quickly oh oh not done not
done now you're done I admit that this
game is just pretty much me sitting here
relaxing and reacting to things that I
see which is totally fine I mean have
the fine brothers do a great job with
that
another episode of youtubers react it
mostly just involves beating and face
face into various objects well I imagine
it's gonna get creative anytime soon
here oh yes why it's come to my
attention that you're not measuring it's
come to my attention that you're a dick
yeah more just beating his face in I
don't even know if a lamp would be able
to kill someone oh why did it what what
why why why what why okay alright that
was my original assumption okay toes
exploded that's the worst punishment a
boss can receive this office would come
and stop me unless they all hate him
just as much
well that was sad alright I know why
this game exists it exists because it is
a stress reliever for everyone who goes
through the Nite Owl my goodness now I
see his eye poking out there well
alright that was lyrical and beautiful
but horrible and terrifying also those
things I have actually worked well then
that was efficient it's like the Joker
with his pencil trick okay I have worked
the nine-to-five before I was an
engineer a company for two years and I
I absolutely hated it so but I was never
homicidal so this is the game remember
[Music]
okay don't do this this is bad
oh yes why is any of this yes oh let me
get that file Joey would never force
energy and you give me what's that that
file shouldn't be there yeah I know you
did it wrong oh my god is that gonna
explode from all the wrong see the
peaceful serenity on his face that's
true bliss am I supposed to do something
no boughs are supposed to wait that one
out
that's Kill Bill levels of blood okay
well once again quick and efficient I
don't even think he expected to do that
okay so I guess the wall or the key I'll
do the hook first I know it's fake of
course it's fake but Wow
mommy when horror movies try to supply
it horror with God I mean it's got a
gross fact on the wall man there's the
wall I was wondering when the wall was
gonna get involved I'm Way happier now
no wait I didn't do this okay
oh right why right here oh god water go
boom I know I know it's totally
hypocritical to save this brutal when
every shooter in every existence is
about brutally shooting blowing up and
killing human enemies I mean
oh man it's got like a calm time ring to
it if you remember calm time ha god
that's a bad way to go how was he
how was he still a blue bling okay
also check out calm time in the
description that's the game where I
literally play a murderer
okay oh good you reads true
enlightenment
oh is that thing well haven't I done
what happened the briefings hi Trixie oh
I fooled you run - okay Oh God
you look like a horror creature out of
cry of fear oh I've only gotten 17 out
24 where are the rest of them I got a
lot of sub pretty mean why are you even
bothering to check before you run away
from the cops oh boy I know what that is
scissors
[Music]
[Applause]
ah I like my worst ones I eat that oh
god oh god I hate neck getting slit oh
my god
Oh whatever I done my chair my fool just
now you're the employee
no what are you doing wait good okay I
thought so okay all right well okay
I think that was out of the scene of a
movie Stabler I don't think I've done
the stapler that seems like everything
else that happened in here so maybe I
have done that no I got a spork ah I
okay alright I've done just about
everything no no no cruel cruel cruel
don't whack your bosses don't whack
anyone get along just get along
put your problems out I guess dance I
take a nap some numbers okay so thank
you all so much for watching if you want
to see another wackier game I played
whack your ex walls eating wasabi it was
a horrible experience on two fronts but
it was probably entertaining for you
guys to watch so check in the
description or the annotation over there
thanks again everybody for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]
Oh